regardez vous avez un PC avec un écran
qui vient tourner ici vous avez un écran
in derrière et l'autre côté vous êtes
sur du OLED 2K lorsque vous avez plus
beaucoup de batterie que vous commencez
un peu à manquer d'autonomie vous vous
inquiétez mais vous faites quoi vous
tournez et vous passez en ink je vous
permettra d'emmener l'autonomie beaucoup
plus loin et ça c'est quand même
vachement cool et au-delà de ça lorsque
vous avez juste des usages pour un peu
de traitement de texte ou des choses qui
sont pas très gourmandes pas besoin de
regarder des films et des séries et bien
vous êtes sur le Inc et lorsque vous
voulez consulter du contenu et bien vous
le tournez vous switch et vous passez
directement ici sur votre dalle OLED
pour ça extrêmement marrant c'est
l'innovation signer le nouveau
d'ailleurs je pense que vous en pensez
dites le moi dans les commentaires